Welcome back everyone this is going to
be my full godzilla versus kong breakdown
in easter eggs there were some easter eggs for
where they're probably going to be taking the
sequels because they just announced this one
of the most successful releases that they've
ever had on hbo max i think it's actually the
current record holder but it's also crushing
it at the box office considering everything
that's happening with movies right now so i
think it's a foregone conclusion that legendary
will eventually renew their license with touhou
and we'll see more godzilla more kong more monster
verse movies careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the movie yet because we'll be talking about
everything but they do leave the movie on a moment
with a couple easter eggs that let you know where
they're going to be taking future movies we've
also got some more information about the original
post credit scene and how that changed so i'll
talk about that too when we get to that part of
the video but we'll just start at the beginning of
the movie work our way through shot by shot talk
about easter eggs as we go along but they opened
the movie on kong revealing that he's being held
at the monarch facility on skull island instead
of being allowed to roam free because they've
been worried godzilla will come for him since the
events of the first godzilla movie a couple years
ago and then king of monsters with everything that
went down they didn't feature kong during that
movie but because of what happened with his war
with king ghidorah and them sort of activating all
the titans like a new alpha surfaces godzilla is
technically the alpha but kong himself is also
canonized as another alpha titan during this
but it's also implied that he was affected by what
was happening between king ghidorah and godzilla
the very truman show looking monarch facility that
they're keeping him in on skull island just looks
so huge that it probably would have taken them
years to build it so i wouldn't be surprised if
they were constructing a version of this starting
way back in the 1970s after the events of kong
skull island but we meet the little girl we learn
about her relationship with kong at some point
there was a really bad storm that basically wiped
out the native tribe that was living there kong
sort of unofficially adopted her the same way
rebecca hall's character kind of adopted her we
learned later in the movie that they've actually
been speaking sign language to each other and kong
is really really smart this whole time but he's
been hiding his intelligence from monarch just
because he doesn't trust them but then they have
the opening credits and there are a whole bunch
of easter eggs through these opening credits
you probably spotted at least some of them
they're done in the same style as all the other
monsterverse movies where they have all these
redacted documents that make all kinds of godzilla
kong other titan references to the classic touhou
films and the way they've weaved those characters
into the modern day monsterverse films they also
use these montages as sort of mini recaps for
the previous films like last time on godzilla
watch and this is what just happened to kong
there's redacted documents built around all the
names of the key crew members like the director
the other main actors when they show the new
director adam wingard's name it reads history
of the titan wars will be explored in a film by
adam wingard that sheds light on previous hidden
truths then it redacts all the documents blacking
everything out really cool side note easter egg
too about this new director if you remember peter
jackson's king kong movie from a long time ago
it's not canon to the new legendary monsterverse
movies but peter jackson was developing a direct
sequel to that movie that would have been a bigger
skull island movie and he brought adam wingard
on to direct it so this was in the early 2000s
the studio obviously didn't like how that king
kong movie performed so they cancelled the sequel
plans but then legendary picked up the reigns
and the license and they did a skull island
movie themselves many years later but one of the
biggest reasons why adam wingard was brought on to
direct godzilla versus kong is because at the time
he was developing that skull island sequel movie
for peter jackson in the early 2000s the executive
who was at the studio overseeing those projects
went on to be hired by legendary to manage their
monsterverse franchise so that same executive
remembered his skull island pitch from years and
years ago and thought that it was a really good
idea so that's the connection and how he wound up
directing godzilla vs kong he also revealed that
the cool aircraft carrier fight scene during the
movie between godzilla and kong they had actually
planned on doing a version of that during the
2014 godzilla movie but had to cut the scene
just because they didn't have the budget to do
it at the time then when they get to alexander
skarsgard's name under his redacted documents it
says needs to prove existence of hollow earth to
salvage tarnished reputation sort of explaining
a little bit about his backstory then there's a
reference to the events of kong skull island with
a picture of bill randa's 1973 expedition john
goodman's character towards the end of the opening
credits they show a whole bunch of monster stats
for the other kaiju we've seen in the monster
verse films the female mutos from the 2014 movie
the skull crawlers from skull island ghidorah's
stats from king of monsters and even though they
killed off mothra during that movie there's
a reference during this movie during godzilla
vs kong to a mothra egg so there are a lot of
people that have theories that godzilla somehow
fertilized mothra's egg and they'll hatch another
mothra child at some point in the future monster
verse films there was also this weird joke during
king of monsters about how titans reproduce like
alright we'll play the titan reproduction reel
while they're in the middle of that senate hearing
then we get the opening scene with the titan truth
podcast brian tyree henry's characters conspiracy
podcast the logo for his podcast with the godzilla
eyeball looks eerily similar to the poster for the
1998 godzilla movie he explains a little about
his backstory how he tried to infiltrate apex
for the past couple of years he's an engineer so
he is genuinely a smart person even though he's
this kind of crackpot character with all these
crazy theories that somehow turn out to be right
at the end of the day we'll talk about that too
because at the end of the movie he sort of teases
kyle chandler's character coming onto his podcast
to talk about aliens and extraterrestrials that's
a whole idea for the space kaiju from the classic
touhou film so i'll talk about that when we get to
that part of the movie for those of you that want
space godzilla gigan or some of the other space
titans to show up he winds up infiltrating the
lower levels of the apex facility to find out that
they've been engineering mechagodzilla's eyeball
he doesn't know exactly what it is at the time
but that's what it is it's one of his eyeballs and
we get that opening godzilla attack which is meant
to be a big reference to the jaws movie so the
way they open with him coming in through the bay
is meant to directly reference jaws especially
the way he comes out of the water they sort of
said that the idea that he's going around the
world attacking all these apex bases we also meet
sara zawa jr sara zawa's son in walter simmons
the company is sort of this glorified amalgam of
a bunch of real world tech companies and he's
sort of meant to be an elon musk type figure
who's developing all these innovations secretly we
find out that's because he's been harvesting a lot
of titan dna and using it to make all these tech
advancements but it's all in service of creating
mechagodzilla the whole thing with sara zawa's son
the way they tease his motivation i guess is the
idea that he wants revenge against the titans for
the death of his father even though technically
his father sara zawa and king of monsters
sacrificed himself because he loved godzilla
so much he loved all the titans and thought that
they were actually good for the earth it kind of
seemed like they killed him off at the end of the
movie but we didn't see his body get melted down
it just seems like his brain got fried because of
that connection but the reason why simmons named
the company apex is because he wanted humans
to become the true apex of life on planet
earth again not the titans then we're reunited
with millie bobby brown's character from the
previous film who's in high school now full-blown
titan conspiracy theorist bit of a red flag there
listening to bernie hayes podcast like she's
addicted to it there was an actual funny tweet
from elon musk himself like i just made those elon
musk references where he said the movie is sort of
a love letter to conspiracy theorists which isn't
necessarily a compliment even though overall i did
like the movie for what it was like it delivered
on the promise of this giant kaiju fight her
character is one of the early people to sort of
learn the godzilla is being provoked attacking
all these apex bases her father kyle chandler's
character still working for monarch he explains
that monarch's whole long-term plan is to use
godzilla as the apex titan the king of all titans
to develop a lasting peaceful coexistence between
all the titans around the planet in humanity we
meet julian dennison's character who seems like
he's just one of millie bobby brown's friends from
school who she ropes in because one he has access
to his brother's van and two a driver's license
this sort of seems like his level of usefulness
during the movie even though he's also the one
at the end of the movie who just splashes all the
whiskey on the controls but then we check in with
alexander skarsgard character nathan lind and
learn about his backstory he used to work with
monarch and his brother trying to gain access to
the hollow earth he's sort of the expert on hollow
earth during the movie which is why he's there
especially at the end of the movie when they go
back to start studying it in earnest and all the
other new titans that they discover down there
we learned that he left monarch though when his
brother got squashed like a pancake because of
the big twist how you enter through the portal to
get to the hollow earth they teased this unlimited
energy source that they kind of explained later
in the movie but they do a lot of hand waving they
don't fully explain what's going on with it only
that it's this unlimited source of clean energy
that's also responsible for the original creation
of the titans like this sort of radioactive
energy source that caused all these animals these
prehistoric monsters to grow so large obviously
they want to use that energy source secretly to
power mechagodzilla systems the actual university
that he works at the denim university i believe is
named after carl denham one of the characters from
the original king kong movie who was also featured
during peter jackson's 2005 remake the way they
visualized the hollow earth 2 is a little bit
like journey to the center of the earth like this
prehistoric land of dinosaurs living underneath
the planet's surface nathan lin's character
goes back to skull island to get eileen andrews
help in getting kong to lead them to the hollow
earth thinking that he's going to be the key the
chains that they put him in are also meant to be a
reference to the 1933 original king kong movie the
change that they put him in during that film they
introduced izzy gonzalez's character she's simon's
daughter to sort of babysit their enterprise and
steal the energy source once they get down to
the hollow earth she serves as sort of like a
throwaway villain during the film but of course we
get godzilla versus kong round one so this whole
aircraft carrier battle is meant to be a reference
to the classic 1960s king kong vs godzilla film
obviously there's a lot of references to that film
during this film like at the end of the movie when
he shoves his axe down kong's throat that's meant
to be a reference to him shoving the tree branch
down his throat during the classic film they also
end the movie in a similar way to the end of the
1960s king kong vs godzilla film with them both
going their separate ways also their backup plan
for getting him to the arctic after they destroy
most of the aircraft carriers carrying him in the
nets with the helicopters is meant to be a direct
reference to king kong vs godzilla where they do
pretty much the exact same thing millie bobby
brown and julian denison's character track down
bernie hayes because apparently he buys so much
bleach they set up the twist with the flask of
whiskey with his wife's ashes in it for later in
the film pouring it on the controls to short out
mechagodzilla systems they break into another
local apex base find the skull crawler eggs and
learn that apex has been cloning and growing their
own titans to test mechagodzilla simmons also says
release number 10 so the skull crawlers are just
one of many different types of titans that they've
been using to test mechagodzilla the whole idea
of humans creating their own titans or growing
biological titans is also a reference to a couple
different kaiju from the classic touhou films
there's destoroyah who's sort of like the thanos
of the monster verse movies in biollante so just
the idea that humans are messing and combining
titan dna could lead to those titans showing up
in future movies when they actually get to the
monarch base in the antarctic with the entrance
to the hollow earth they teased the idea that
maybe some of kong's family might still be down
inside there i think potentially they're leaving
that idea for future films but you do see a lot of
artifacts and monuments to kong's ancestors down
there you see all this massive infrastructure in
these tunnels going down to the hollow earth so it
seems like monarch has been developing this for a
long time but the way they visualize the actual
portal in traveling to hollow earth is meant to
be a reference to 2001 space odyssey where it's
almost like you're evolving into the star child
by traveling into the hollow earth the danger they
explain is that this big gravity inversion so you
get squashed like a pancake unless you have a way
to counteract the gravity effects but it's also a
way to explain how humans have not traveled to
the hollow earth before now but there's so many
structures down in the hollow earth that seem
like they were created by prehistoric humans or
ancient races that worship the titans they explain
a little of this during king of monsters as well
these ancient races that worship them like gods
they tease that there are tons of lesser titans
just flying all over the place down here they
haven't completely explained the only ones they've
officially explained are the war bats that kong
winds up fighting here then taking down and then
later the bat tightens inside the temple the rest
are all sort of speculation as to who they'll wind
up being some of them do look like newer versions
of classic touhou titans but that just remains to
be seen in potential future sequels down here in
the hollow earth he finds the ancient axe weapon
that looks like it's built from one of godzilla's
ancestor's dorsal spikes in a mudo bone then
learns that he can charge it using the radioactive
energy from the planet's core inside this
specially designed godzilla mural so if you wonder
why there's this godzilla design that lights up
that's wrapped around this giant kong throne
that's because the ancient humans that worship
kong's ancestors were just paying reference to
that relationship but then millie bobby brown and
team conspiracy wind up in mechagodzilla's holding
facility and they learn what they've been doing
with him this whole time so they've been using
these other titans they grow to test his systems
and they've stole at least one of ghidorah's heads
and are using it and his brain material his brain
matter as a living super computer that allows
them to basically remote pilot mechagodzilla
like a pacific rim jaeger which is funny because
legendary also made the pacific rim movies it sort
of creates this mental link with the ai that they
use inside mechagodzilla's body to control him
once they wind up stealing and replicating the
energy source to fully power up mechagodzilla
the way they want to though it somehow shorts out
the connection with their control systems and even
though they don't fully explain what's going on
here they just kind of hand wave over a lot of it
a lot of people believe that it's actually the
remnants of ghidorah's psychic energy combining
with the ai inside mechagodzilla's body that
goes rogue after the energy source shorts out
the connection so it's also a bit of a reference
to mecha ghidorah which is also one of the titans
from the classic touhou films but mecca ghidorah
looks very different has a very different origin
story a lot of people are also thinking that this
version of mechagodzilla is more similar to kiryu
because that was actually a mechagodzilla cyborg
built around the bones of the original godzilla
and this version of mechagodzilla does incorporate
some organic parts and abilities from ghidorah
there are many different mecha versions
of the titans in the classic touhou films
also when it winds up taking out the alpha skull
crawler with its beam weapon that's also meant
to be a direct reference to the first monster vs
godzilla movie where godzilla takes out the mudo
using what they're calling his kiss of death so
to speak with his atomic breath only now it's
mechagodzilla giving his version of the kiss of
death but any time they power up mechagodzilla's
systems godzilla can detect him around the world
so obviously he then comes to hong kong godzilla
did also attack hong kong during 1995's godzilla
vs destoroyah for more of you hoping that they'll
eventually work up to that character in the new
monsterverse films but when kong winds up charging
his axe godzilla also detects the energy source
all the way down inside the hollow earth and
his atomic breath is so powerful that he blasts a
hole straight down there so obviously even though
kong winds up in the hollow earth at the end of
the movie because godzilla was so easily able to
blast a hole down there it'd probably be just as
easy for him to travel down there as well there's
also a godzilla roar over the ending credits scene
too i'll explain that in a second too because it's
also a reference to classic touhou films kong
sees it as a challenge and works his way back up
and they have their first big rematch in hong kong
round two kong's able to win round two because of
the charged axe but then directly after it after
the axe loses his charge godzilla is able to beat
him down again so that's sort of like round three
technically goes back to godzilla but that's when
mecha godzilla breaks free of his containment goes
rogue busts out of the mountain and then fights
godzilla so you have godzilla vs mechagodzilla and
he winds up kicking his ass pretty bad the whole
idea is that mechagodzilla is supposed to be way
more powerful than godzilla and kong on their own
until they team up and get the boost from the
charged axe weapon titans teaming up to fight
mechagodzilla is also a reference to the classic
touhou film usually it winds up being a team up
to take down mechagodzilla they show off all of
his abilities he's got a version of atomic breath
it's been supercharged because of the new energy
source from the hollow earth his mechanical tail
acts like a drill i believe that's also meant
to be a reference to classic touhou monsters
it also seems like there might be a tail laser
too but he never winds up using it he's got a
very hadouken-like charge attack he's got missiles
all up and down his dorsal spike assembly that he
gives off he's got booster rockets all over his
body making him way more agile than godzilla and
kong and it allows him a limited ability to fly
even though he doesn't really use it that much
during the movie then because godzilla had just
taken down kong and his heartbeat is slowing
they actually recharge him so to speak or revive
him using the hollow earth craft to zap him with
electricity which is also a reference to the 1960s
king kong vs godzilla film where they powered king
kong up with a big bolt of electricity he winds up
stopping mechagodzilla right before he's able to
land the killing blow on godzilla then they sort
of tag team him until godzilla charges up the axe
again enabling kong to land the killing blow on
mechagodzilla they have a little bit of a final
standoff like a bro off alpha moment like they're
not best buds or anything in this moment it's more
like a truce like okay we're gonna go our separate
ways we both have our parts of the earth that we
rule over then when they go their separate ways
that's meant to be a reference to the end of the
1960s king kong versus godzilla movie where they
both sort of swim off in different directions and
even though we have that hollow earth scene at
the end of the film the true last scene of the
film you have that godzilla roar that's meant
to be a reference to godzilla's roar at the end
of king kong vs godzilla in the 1960s meant to
let you know that godzilla survived their attack
because it's actually kong that you see swimming
off instead of godzilla but then after a short
time jump we learned that monarch has created
a new station down inside the hollow earth to
study kong as well as the rest of the hollow earth
in earnest the whole thing with this hollow earth
station scene is the director actually came out a
little while ago and explained this was actually
meant to be the original post-credits scene they
filmed it that way but then at the last minute
they decided to just put it at the end of the
film instead of in the post credits because they
wanted whoever winds up making the sequel movie to
have more flexibility in where the story picks up
so there is an actual post-credits scene for the
movie it's just that you're seeing it right here
at the end of the movie instead of after the
credits then over the actual credits you hear
godzilla's roar just to remind you oh he's still
out there and he will come back the whole idea
with sequels though is that legendary's license
with touhou is up and they're kind of waiting
to see how this film does financially it sounds
like it's doing really well so i do think they
will eventually renew that license do more films
but the whole idea that sequels will probably
revolve around what's happening down here in the
hollow earth they'll get into more mythology in
the history of the titans but within the monster
verse their sort of version of avengers infinity
war avengers end game they would build up to would
be a version of destroy all monsters which is sort
of a battle royale with a whole bunch of titans
also you have their version of thanos which would
be like destoroyah you have other space kaiju
like brian tyree henry's character tells kyle
chandler's character will you please come on my
podcast and start talking about extraterrestrials
remember ghidorah is also from outer space
they've already canonized that so that means
that other titans also can come from outer space
so everybody let me know in the comments if you
spotted any big easter eggs in the movie that i
didn't talk about during the video and what you
want them to do with the next sequel movie there's
a whole bunch of new trailers that drop so i'll
try to do videos for those as quick as possible
my full falcon and winter soldier episode 4 video
will also post on friday just like normal way
you wait for everything click here for my other
godzilla vs kong ending and end credit scene video
and click here for my brand new loki trailer in
marvel easter eggs thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!